there is a really big backlog leading to  crazy wait times for those that need  passport issuance and renewals right now  we are looking at five months and three  months for expedited service all due to  a big backlog at the state department  due to cobit regulations when it comes  to the expiration dates on your passport  here is something flight expert willis  orlando says a lot of people don't  realize  if you want to travel internationally in  the coming months check your passport  right now because remember many  countries require not only that your  passport be valid to enter but that  would be valid for three or even six  months after when you enter in order to  be allowed in most airlines are waiving  change fees if you don't receive your  passport in time and there is some  recourse available as well if you reach  out to your federally elected officials  for help sometimes they can help move  this process along a little bit more  smoothly